his latest book is talking to strangers
what we should know about the people we
don't know Malcolm Gladwell welcome to
The Economist I'll thank you so tell me
first what is a stranger what is a
stranger a stranger is someone you know
I suppose who we have who
we have limited understanding of their
perspective backgrounds culture
tradition or another way maybe a more
interesting way to say it is a stranger
is someone who we know in only one
dimension what presents itself to us yes
and like me you're a journalist
we've spent our lives talking to
strangers in the hope of pursuing
something that we hoped was truthful and
enlightening what draws you to talking
to strangers the point of my book is
simply to highlight the reasons why
those kinds of encounters sometimes go
awry which i think is a an enormous the
important issue because we are drawing
more and more into interactions with
people who we don't fully understand
well let's look a bit more about why
this matters because if it was simply
about the way that we behave when we
meet other people and a kind of social
politeness that would be one thing but
you actually think that there is is
damage to the consequences of these
misunderstandings and the story of
Sandra bland is obviously very
motivating for you I think it's really
one of the reasons that you wanted to
write the book in the first place yes
Sandra bland is one of those wave of
cases of encounters between police
officers in an African Americans that
were for about three years a few years
ago in America these were front and
center they were about a dozen of these
high-profile cases and she was a young
woman young black woman who was coming
from a job interview in a small Texas
town gets pulled over for a minor
traffic infraction by a white police
officer their subsequent encounter was
captured on the video cameras a
dashboard camera of the of the cop and
they their encounter goes awry they get
it essentially get into an argument he
eventually pulls her out of the car
arrests her she coats put him jail and
she commits suicide Twitter's that her
it's one of the most to me it was anyway
the most heart-wrenching and also
baffling of these encounters and I when
I the more I thought about it the more I
realized that it was a powerful way into
this general problem that had been that
I've been thinking about for quite some
time which is that there seems to be
something very wrong with the strategies
we're using when we approach strangers
in other words the same things that in
human interaction that make perfect
sense when I know you clearly don't work
when I don't know you and that so I set
out to write a book that begins and ends
with the Sandra bland story begins by
laying out the mystery so what how could
a completely banal encounter in the
middle of the day between a police
officer and a woman over a failure to
signal changing lanes I mean the most
Posterous ly trivial of infractions lead
to tragedy fundamentally when you listen
to this harrowing bit of audiotape of
the initial encounter between a police
officer and and and Sandra bland and you
see the ways in which the police officer
in particular systematically
misunderstands where she's coming from
for example he does not he picks up on
the fact that she is emotionally
distressed but thinks but weeds it as
malicious and dangerous and not as
someone who is you know she is someone
with a long history of emotional
instability he doesn't see that he
thinks oh she's trying to hurt me right
right now so there was a case where he
needed to know more about her before he
made this decision about whether she was
dangerous or not that requires that
required curiosity on his part Abe
acquired more time it required some
common bond of understanding and Trust
between the two of them all kinds of
things were required but her what really
what he really needed was better insight
into who she was as human being if he's
gonna make this consequential decision
about whether she deserves to be
arrested or not he's got to know more
give us a quick menu of what your
theories are as to why we so
persistently understand people in this
could cause a lot broader than the
Sandra bland case there's a wonderful
brilliant psychologist named Tim Devine
who has who has come up with an idea
week which he calls default to truth who
was trying to answer this long-standing
puzzle in psychology which is why are
humans human beings so bad at detecting
lies and you would think that we would
be good at it
you would think that evolution would
have yes yeah who were adept at knowing
when they were being deceived it turns
out not to be true at all well suppose
the evidence if I give you a series of
videotapes half of which are people
telling lies and half of what you people
telling the truth
and I ask you to tell me which is which
you will get about 52 to 53 percent of
the answer is correct so I might
conclude that roughly I'm just guessing
it's almost 50/50 issue this is the
lines big point what you're doing is you
are you are entering the process with
the assumption that people are telling
the truth and you are so you have a
default of truth your overwhelming
inclination is to say that's truthful
and then in a small number of cases you
where there is there seems like an
overwhelming evidence of deception
you're willing to challenge that
conception so you're basically saying
true true true true true true true mmm
maybe false choo choo choo choo that's
what you're doing and he says that's
powerfully characteristic of human
beings because that's why we've able
been able to build society functioning
societies it doesn't work if you are
skeptical of everything people say we
couldn't have this conversation if we
were challenging each other out of every
moment you couldn't build a financial
system you couldn't you wouldn't send
your children to school if you didn't
default to choose right so it's useful
it also has tripwires and what's the
difference between that and confirmation
bias I would think
mission bias is a kind of subset of this
general tendency I think what LaVon is
describing is something powerfully
fundamental about the way human beings
make sense of the world and the
confirmation biases would I would think
of as a as a specific offshoot of this
that has to do with the way we deal with
information I suppose the squeezing
question I had as I went on through the
book I might come to intelligence and
intended to seating in a moment but I
wanted to ask you about the Amanda Knox
case you say she spent four years in an
Italian prison for the crime of not
behaving the way we think people were
supposed to behave after their roommate
Meredith Kercher net is murdered again
now you see that's where I know a little
bit about that case she was in
exonerated the police work was terrible
the forensics were terrible and all the
rest but nonetheless there was an a
still a bit of an unknowability about
aspects of the case so you as far as
you're concerned she's sort of judged
for a certain way that she was behaving
but I wondered whether you were looking
for that so you found it this actually
goes back to Tim Levine's arguments
about why is it that we are so bad at
understanding whether someone is telling
us a lie or the truth and he says that
there are a specific category of people
communicators who we have trouble with
and he calls them people who are
mismatched and by mismatch he means that
if you if you look at a universe of
people who are who are trying to judge
the truth or falsity of a statement you
will see that they always get the same
ones right and the same ones wrong so we
get we get people right when those be
when there is a match between the
emotional intention of the person and
the way those emotions are manifested in
their demeanor and their effect and
their facial expressions and all those
kinds of things so a matched person
would be if someone is nervous and
they're sweating visibly and
their knee is bouncing up and down
that's matched those are we have a
stereotype in our head about what
nervousness looks like and here we have
a nervous person matching the stereotype
yes so if I ask you is that person
nervous and you say yes they are you're
gonna get that person right but there's
a category of people who will sweat
profusely and bounce their knee up and
down when they're not nervous at all
right those kinds of people we have
trouble with yes we overwhelmingly
people around the world in many
different cultures believe that gaze
aversion looking away being shifty eyed
is a sign of deception right when
someone is lying and they shift their
eyes we're all good at saying they're
lying but there are lots of people who
don't shift their eyes and lie and shift
their eyes and aren't lying
they are mismatched and we have trouble
with them Amanda Knox was a very
convenient example of mismatch because
it's a case we're all familiar with and
if you read the books on Amanda Knox or
they watch the documentaries they'll all
come back to the same issue which is
that she seemed she acted in a way that
was weird
what they're saying is they're all
harping on the same she's mismatched
she's in Rasik classic mismatch she's an
awkward slightly immature teenager who
does not match Italian and English
tabloid stereotypes of what distressed
roommates are supposed to be distressed
room is supposed to behave let's look at
the implications of changing world of
data and privacy or less and less
privacy and the impact of if social
media that must challenge your working
idea of what a stranger is at all I mean
what am I supposed to make of my ex
thousand Twitter followers and your ex
many more I mean we are now sharing so
many more intimate details of our lives
and our thoughts with many more people
does that change anything I think it
makes some of these fundamental issues
that we have with those we don't know
much more consequential I mean I think
that the the trajectory that we are on
as a world is that the number of
encounters that we have with people who
we have a limited knowledge is
multiplying that's why I sort of thought
this was a pressing issue to write about
what about AI in the notion that AI can
hold the solution to some of our biases
it's something we write about a lot of
the economists actually using programs
to to look better adapt locations so
we're not subconsciously screening out
candidates who may not suit the view of
what a person should look like who works
for an organization how do you feel
about that for I have funny I have a
chapter I'm in my book that deals with
this precise issue which is which I'm
talking about in the context of judges
making bail decisions so the judge has
to the defendant stands in front of the
judge the judge has to decide do I
release this person until trial or do I
put them in prison until trial are they
likely to commit another crime in the
interim or not that is an extremely
difficult decision and when we look at
how effective judges are at gauging
predicting the dangerousness of a
defendant they're not very good at it
and when we look at how machine learning
systems and AI systems and algorithms do
they tend to do better actually much
better than the judge right so there's
an instance where we have clear evidence
that a disembodied computer can do can
be more accurate in making a prediction
about a human being than a judge can
that is a clear opportunity for
improving the system but we need to be
artful in the way we combine these two
sources of insight you can't throw out
the right answer is not to throw out the
judge because that undermines the
legitimacy of the system but at the same
time the right answer is don't close the
door to tools that can help the judge
make a better decision just because they
have to be scary or newfangled do you
need to do both you need to be we need
to be thoughtful about how we can
integrate
the the the wisdom of things like AI
with human decision-making systems that
can confer legitimacy on the process we
can't end without talking about politics
and where what you've written about it
leaves our muddled politics on both
sides of the Atlantic at the moment sir
I think I'll just ask you who in public
life do you think popular conception his
most misunderstood anyone running for
public office has to conform to the
principles of transparency if they
expect to proceed you cannot be Amanda
Knox and run for public office right
because you're asked to present yourself
in very broad forums to people who don't
know you in the slightest
and if you deviate from our expectation
of how that how your behavior is
supposed to proceed you'll be penalized
what do you obviously not penalized
otherwise you wouldn't have Donald Trump
in the White House who in every sense
did not accord with what oh I think
candidate for the presidency look I know
to the contrary I would say that there
was no we're talking with slightly
different things here but Donald Trump's
interstates and his outer
representations are perfectly matched
when he is disgusted he shows disgust
when he I mean no man has ever done less
to mask his his his inner feelings than
Donald Trump which is I think a powerful
reason why he is so popular is that that
codes too many people as authenticity
right he makes no attempt whatsoever to
filter his feelings they they spill out
of him at 3 o'clock in the morning on
Twitter I mean this is so you know that
is a to my point I think that politics
powerfully favors those who have this
direct correspondence between the way
they feel and the way they act
particularly contemporary politics which
are so concerned with public persona and
so the aura of celebrity and all those
kinds of things that's interesting but
almost I'm sure you don't mean this
politically it sort of almost a kind
reading of Donald Trump you think he's
actually he's made for the job
no why no I mean that he's
I mean it's a corresponds between these
interstates in his representations I
that's not a value judgment that's a an
observation about the need the way he
expresses his character I happen to
think that's wholly inappropriate and
that in fact to do it to be an effective
leader you have to learn to mask your
inner feelings which is to my point
though going back to the question of who
is misunderstood it's becoming
increasingly difficult for people who
are mismatched to operate successfully
in public life the expectations culture
is a strong yes we have come to
emphasize so much personal the validity
and importance of personal
representation that we have penalised an
entire group of people who may be
extraordinarily capable but don't match
this kind of stereotypical picture of
how how they're supposed to present
themselves emotionally welcomed bad will
no longer stranger thank you very much
thank you